here is video of a woman by the name of
mara gay and she you may remember her
i'm going to talk about my personal
clash with her in just a moment she is a
writer for the new york times who often
calls everyone racist that's her main
thing everyone's racist uh and uh what
does she think is happening right now
well she's on the televised mental
institution of msnbc explaining that
it's not because of all the printing of
the money and all that stuff it's really
because you know it's the people on the
right they're mean as we see american
democracy has expanded to include uh
different people including non-white
americans that along with a changing
economy and stressors on the middle
class have really combined to create
this combustive environment in which uh
you know you're looking for somebody
some explanation
for uh what you're seeing around you and
i think unfortunately the right wing
media has been all too quick to uh
to blame non-white americans to blame
democratic institutions and uh it's
essentially you know if we don't control
it well then let's burn the whole thing
down
and and that's what this is this is
about power and so there are some people
in america who are more interested in
having power than democracy if they
can't have power through the democracy
they'd rather not have the democracy and
so there is a divide between those like
the new york post apparently it's great
to see the wall street journal who are
saying no
we still want that democracy and those
who say you know what
let's just let's just as long as we're
in in control
it doesn't matter the democratic
institutions don't matter the democracy
doesn't matter forget it all it's not
scary
okay so everything they say
everything they say is a lie right it is
confession through projection everything
they say is a lie um who is blaming
non-white americans for what's going on
here have you guys heard anyone blame
non-white americans
anyone no who's oh those brown people
are the ones printing all the money
they're the ones that destroyed the
supply chain
no nobody's saying this they make up
this nonsense and actually if you go
back later and you watch clips she's
kind of laughing as she says it at the
beginning because she knows it's
nonsense you know who's doing it and i
hate to play the identity politics game
it's old white liberals like janet
yellen and joe biden
that are doing it and whoever is pulling
their string so i'll throw barack obama
in there even though he's not white or
he's half white or something i don't
really care anyway i don't like this
mara gay girl very much and it reminded
me when i saw the clip you may remember
this from about a year ago
if you look at the bottom there that's a
new york times piece she did an
interview with andrew yang who is a
failed presidential candidate who had an
embarrassingly pathetic run for the new
york city mayoral race and in the
interview that she did with him uh she
referred to this show as the dave rubin
show which it's called the reuben report
fyi and she said that i regularly host
white supremacists uh so i kind of went
off on her over there she did not issue
an apology nor a correction but that's
just how these people operate um can i
get the list of white supremacists we've
had on the show i'm trying to throw a
dinner party on friday and i'd love to
get a bunch of people over here what a
white what do white supremacists eat i
feel like it's a lot it's a lot of white
a lot of wonder bread probably a lot of
wonder bread and butter or something um
anyway these people are just silly you
guys get it they're just silly silly
people and they lie about everything
right they're hypocrites and they lie
about everything